[Music]
the original rollercoaster tycoon or
RCT for shorts came out on the 31st of
March 1999 so today marks the 20th
anniversary of the theme park management
simulator that changed the tycoon genre
and honestly changed my life as well so
I figured there'd never be a better time
than now to revisit this draft script
for a video essay that I wrote in early
2016 and ended up abandoning because I
realized that it totally turned into one
of these weird overly pretentious video
essays packed with unnecessarily verbose
language also a lot of videos about this
game have come out since then so I'm not
too sure if I could contribute much of
meaning to the public discourse that
said it's the 20th anniversary of this
game and it's the very reason that I
even have this YouTube channel so
there's a lot that I want to say about
it from my own perspective and at least
I want to pay respect to it so if you're
down for it please allow me to gush
about ICT for as long as I feel like and
in the meantime I'm showing off some of
my favorite bikes and coasters that I've
made throughout the years of playing the
game scenarios including the expansion
packs part 1 what is roller coaster
tycoon roller coaster tycoon is a game
that almost everybody has played or
heard about so I don't think it needs
much of an introduction it's a
simulation game in which you try to
build your own virtual theme parks
across various maps in different
scenarios all while trying to reach the
goals that the game sets for you which
usually revolve around attracting a
certain number of guests to your park
but other objectives include getting a
certain number of coasters done or
reaching a monthly operating profits the
game was created by Chris Sawyer who
programmed the whole thing in x86
programming language and I'm no
programming expert but I've heard that
that is super impressive because while
most programming languages exist to make
programming more easy for humans because
the data that a computer reads is
most unintelligible to us assembly is
about as close as you can get to
directly importing commands into the
hardware this meant that the programming
of roller coaster tycoon must have taken
a huge amount of time and effort but
it's also why the game works so well a
game from the 90s being able to simulate
thousands of guests rollercoasters and
rides
all at the same time without lagging is
really impressive and to this day it
still works really well on pretty much
every system ever in my opinion a very
underrated part of the game is the
graphics usually people point out how
they've aged quite well due to the
pixelated - the isometric perspective
but again this is particularly
impressive because it's all done by one
person Simon Foster who 3d model many of
the assets that you see in the game and
rendered them from various perspectives
in 2d to create tile sets which all of
the rollercoasters rides and scenery
that you see are made out of he also has
a YouTube channel with a really
interesting video revealing how he made
the tile sets which I'll link down below
in the description apparently one
coaster type alone required 8,000 unique
images just for the movement of the
trains and I can't begin to think about
how much work it would have taken him to
create all of the graphics for the game
finally Alistair Brimble who made the
game sounds and music rounds up the just
about the three-man team that created
the original game I should also mention
David Ellis who according to the games
credits supplied additional sounds and
coincidentally he's quite well known
within the roller coaster enthusiasts
community he also has a YouTube channel
with a lot of great rollercoaster
content including some POVs that I'll
link down below as well as for the sound
and music in the game I think they've
also have gone into the collective
consciousness I don't think I can ever
hear this sound or this sound without
feeling super nostalgic about it
the opening music is just as iconic and
really every time I hear Johann Strauss
jr. waltz I'm reminded of the
merry-go-round soundtrack in Oct as for
the gameplay itself
it's very simple each level starts with
a unique map and setting and it's your
job to lay down paths where guests can
walk place down rides and shops for them
and build your own rollercoasters for
them to ride and micromanage the out of
all of it until you've successfully
reached your objective ahead of the
deadline and I think that's what makes
simulation games like this so good each
level has a beginning and an end but
everything in between is up to the
player that said something that RCT
arguably does better than similar games
like SimCity or Zoo Tycoon is allowing
for player creativity especially with
the amazing coaster building tools part
two why roller coaster tycoon is just so
good there are many videos already out
there taking apart what makes this game
so good I'll link some in the
description below you get the drill by
now I hope but to avoid repeating others
I'll try to highlight some of my
favorite parts of this game that so far
haven't received as much appreciation as
they deserve in my opinion although in
some ways I guess I'm also kind of
building on some of these other videos
as well so I highly recommend watching
these as well especially if you're
interested in the game if there's
anything that most people seem to agree
on
it's that what makes RCT so good is the
perfect combination of management and
creativity the coaster builder and
scenery options make it a perfect
vehicle for creative expression but the
management of profits guests and
maintenance keep it engaging design dog
has explained it better than I ever
could but there is a real sense of
progression that makes the game as
addicting as it is although I do argue
that this sense of progression doesn't
just come from the ever increasing
profits and guest counts and other
number related things like that they
also come very much from everything else
you do in the game for one example
listen to what you hear when you just
open up the first scenario and now
listen to what it sounds like when
you've almost completed the scenario and
you've managed to turn it into a
successful theme park
as your Park grows officially the audio
reinforces the sense of progression and
as your screen slowly fills up with
rides and roller coasters you'll hear
more guests mumbling and rights rattling
there very simple sounds and on their
own they're not very impressive but I
think that the way they work together to
create this wall of theme park noise
that gets louder and louder the more
complex your Park rows is really cool
you get positive feedback like this for
every write that you build with more
guests filling the park your profit
increasing and even a rising Park rating
along with the more and more completed
look and feel of the park sure you have
complete freedom over what you want to
build but the game never lets go of its
management and for everything you build
it really feels like you're one step
closer to the final goal this is even
through in a very literal sense coasters
with more path interaction difficult to
design elements like interlocking loops
and overall more scenery have a higher
excitement rating and are therefore more
profitable so not only are they better
from a creative standpoint I suppose but
also from a management standpoint parks
with a lot of well laid out theming will
win rewards and attract more guests and
make the guests more happy as they're
walking through the park as well and the
further you progress into the game the
more researched rides and themes you
unlock giving you more and more options
to design your own parks our city isn't
just a management made more engaging by
ending a creative aspect on top of it I
think these elements are in many ways
very much intertwined that said it's not
perfect and a pure focus on management
can easily overpower any creative
aspects of the game at least in a visual
sense once you know that all you have to
do to win scenario is is to copy and
paste the same shuttle loop layout over
and over again creating the most
terrible but efficient theme park that
honestly works in pretty much every
scenario the game is basically broken
because of that I do think you need to
be willing to try and be creative
because otherwise it's very easy to
choose your
out of every scenario in other words
because it's so open it's really only as
good as you're willing to make it as a
player for me however this combination
of gameplay and creativity has always
remained enjoyable and no game since has
been able to balance these elements
quite as well I think and that includes
the sequels and spiritual successors of
the game so yeah part three the sequels
roller coaster tycoon became a huge
success and it was followed up by
rollercoaster tycoon 2 in 2002 and
rollercoaster tycoon 3 in 2004 on the
surface our city too didn't change the
game that much it was pretty much made
by the same small team of developers the
graphics are almost exactly the same and
the gameplay didn't change much either
what made RCT 2 so different from the
predecessor was the introduction of the
scenario editor allowing players to
create their own scenarios and also more
or less make a de-facto sandbox mode RCT
two later got expansion packs made by
frontier developments who went on to
create rollercoaster tycoon 3 with some
help from Chris Sawyer but really
frontier as the designers of the game
this game was completely different from
the first two as it's in 3d and it
introduced a real sandbox mode as well
as the ability to ride roller coasters
now the ability to ride roller coasters
basically changed the game forever and
made it much more immersive than
predecessors but the gameplay and
rollercoaster mechanics remained largely
unchanged now I won't say that any of
these games is per se better or worse
than any other all three of them are
amazing and they all want their own fans
for good reasons I do think it's
interesting that some people like me
prefer the first one over the other two
while a large number of people seem to
think that RCT two is clearly the best
game because it adds a lot of contents
without removing anything that was
already there and the key difference is
in why people play these games I think
our CT 2's greatest strengths the
scenario editor is also kind of its
greatest weakness since you basically
have got powers from the start the game
seem to shift away
from scenario mode as there are now less
scenarios than the first game and of
course you get them all right from the
start that said all of the new rights
and scenery contents totally makes up
for it
more than ICT whenever did our CT 2
allows the player to live the fantasy of
designing their own theme park from
scratch with almost any type of coaster
or theme they could come up with and
honestly I have yet to see any theme
park simulator with as many coaster
types as ICT 2 had outside of the ICT
franchise there's a good reason why this
game still has an active community to
this day it's just the most well rounded
isometric theme park simulation game our
61 is perhaps a better game but RCT two
is undeniably a better creative tool and
honestly if we consider unofficial ICT
games - I think open ICT - which is a
free open-source version of ICT - with
online multiplayer mode is probably the
best game in the franchise that said I
have a bone to pick with the ICT two
scenarios so please hear me out here by
now we get the whole thing about
creative play and management's but it
wouldn't work so well without
well-designed levels and what makes the
original RCT scenario so good is not per
se how nice they look but the fact that
there is intentional or not always a
strong relationship between the
objectives that you're tasked with and
the map that you're given forest
frontier is a quick one-year
introduction scenario with a low
necessary guest counts so it gives you a
very small and open space with enough
room to freely build but not so much
that it becomes overwhelming and you can
constantly get used to how the game
works and fill in the map in that one
year Rainbow Valley on the other hand is
an infamous late-game scenario because
it forbids you from removing any trees
or terraforming in any way but it cuts
you some slack by giving you a map with
the river running through it where there
will always be some kind of open space
to build even if it is quite difficult
to work with this interplay between a
scenarios objective and the map it
provides to reach it is an element which
RCT - -
the boat on for me and I think it's the
main reason why so many people dislike
it scenarios but aren't quite able to
put their finger on why they feel that
way for me at least it's why I prefer
vanilla rct1 / vanilla ICT - and why RCT
- with our 31 scenarios in other words
open RCT - is the best thing ever
now back to why RCT two scenarios suck
there are some examples that always come
to mind for me so there's these two maps
called extreme Heights and lucky Lake
the challenges for both of these parks
are that their ratings are not allowed
to go below 700 which is quite hard to
do and that both maps feature very
difficult terrain a hilly desert and a
large lake respectively but with
unlimited money there is no reason for
extreme Heights to have these hills or
for lucky Lake to be a lake because in
both cases you can very easily just take
your infinite money and completely
flatten the land and come up with any
kind of theme Pike that you want
contrast this with leafy Lake from the
original game for instance where the
lack of space around the lake actually
puts forward a challenge to the
scenarios objective and I think it's
clear to see why this scenario is often
considered to be more fun now to nuance
this a bit and to show that I'm not just
cherry picking these examples rct2 does
do it right in some cases rainbow
valleys objectives for instance state
that you cannot build above three
Heights so the level design consists of
huge Hills that allow you to build large
terrain conforming coasters to fit with
this height restriction that said I
think this is a major reason why so many
people feel like RCT one scenarios are
more memorable and more fun but don't
really know why they feel that way some
things just right about the way the
scenarios play out because there's a
connection between what the game gives
you and what the game asks you to make
that's and the fact that you actually
have to play the scenarios to unlock
more which is a pretty good way to get
you motivated and also the research
department is actually necessary in RCT
one because you start out with only if
you rides most of the time unlike the
majority of ICT to scenarios where
you're given way too many rides right
from the start I do like our city to
though just as much as the other games I
just think that the scenarios dropped
the ball in some ways and maybe this is
why some people prefer the original over
the second one the critical reception
was also a little bit less good on the
second game but to be honest I don't
think this is really too relevant
looking back now because most of the
criticism was that the second game
didn't really add much to the first game
and it was more of an expansion pack
than a real new game but to be honest
the original game is just that good I
can't really blame them for not changing
anything about it and finally rct3
arguably continued down the same path
ICT 2 went and really just took it a
step further the game being in 3d and
including a sandbox mode only made it
more popular as a creative tool where
you can design and ride your own roller
coasters and even walk around in your
own theme parks the game added tons of
other content as well like firework
shows water parks and even animals so
you can build zoos in this game out of
any of these games this is probably the
one that I spend most time playing and I
never really got tired of the sandbox
mode because there's just so much
content and pretty much from 2010 to
2015 this is the game that I made videos
off on YouTube and this is the game
that's sort of the reason that I'm even
here and making this video right now
that said people never really seem to
play this game for the actual campaign
mode and even if I do think the career
mode is kind of underrated and
definitely really ambitious
it just doesn't live up to how its
height the management in the original
game is also the graphics didn't really
age well even if this game was
impressive when it came out I might go
back to this at some point in the future
if I get my disc back and maybe I'll
make some videos of some of the coasters
that I never finished in this game but
that said going back to this right now
really doesn't feel as intuitive
or friendly as going back to roller
coaster tycoon one or two there's just
something about the strange cartoony
very low poly style of 3d arts that the
game has part for what's next it's hard
to say what impact roller coaster tycoon
had on the simulation game genre twenty
years ago obviously it created a trilogy
that remains popular and well respected
to this day but the last entry in this
trilogy came up 15 years ago what else
did it bring since then okay
so just because I need to get this out
of the way there have been many attempts
by Atari who to this day owned the
rights to the franchise to milk it for
all it's worth and I don't think there
is anything I can say here that hasn't
been said many times already aside from
the ports these games are all explicitly
made to trick customers into buying them
because name recognition I guess while
keeping their development costs as low
as possible some of them are better than
others but they're all bad I'm gonna
list them all here just to get this over
with and so you know what not to spend
your money on
there's roller coaster tycoon 3d roller
coaster tycoon for mobile rollercoaster
tycoon world
roller coaster tycoon touch which is a
port of roller coaster tycoon world and
most recently roller coaster tycoon
adventures which is a ports of roller
coaster tycoon touch which was a port of
roller coaster tycoon world this time
it's for the switch and then there's
also roller coaster tycoon adventures
for PC which you can find on the Epic
Games Store which is not something that
we all have but that's what it's limited
to unfortunately and yeah this game is a
part of roller coaster tycoon adventures
for the switch which was a port of
roller coaster tycoon touch which was a
port of roller coaster tycoon world
I hope row up to speed there honestly I
think at the moment there are really
only two true spiritual successors to
RCT there is planet coaster developed by
frontier and led by some of the people
who worked on rct2 and
three and on the other hand there is
also pork attacks which is a standalone
indie game which takes a lot of
inspiration from the original ICT but it
doesn't quite have the same connection
to it I don't want to dedicate too much
of my time to these other games in a
video which should be a celebration of
rollercoaster tycoon but in my opinion
anyone who wants to get back into this
small genre of theme park sims should
look into either of these two games
they're both great for very different
reasons and maybe that's something I'll
get into later that said they're pretty
much the bulk of my channel so I'm not
too sure if I'm ready to make a
comparison video of these and honestly I
both love them equally for very
different reasons anyway that's it I
feel like there's a lot more I could say
about this game but I'm already
procrastinating on my homework by
writing this script now so I'll leave it
at this let me know what you loved about
the original roller coaster tycoon
though and I'll get back to making
videos on whichever new RCT inspired
game comes out